this is a production of Cornell
University
I'm here to tell you today about our
ashtead collection workshop so we
started this effort actually three years
ago we were funded got a three-year
grant from the northeastern area state
and private forestry Association and
essentially we were tasked with doing
five workshops in New York State each of
the three years to educate people on you
know the fact that we're losing our
Ashlee's across the states and now
across much of the East and in addition
to these workshops we were test with
making 150 collections over the course
of the three years of the three most
common species that we have here in the
state so here on the right hand side of
the slide you have the Latin fraxinus is
the genus fresh so we have Americana
which is the white ash pencil vaniqa
which is the green ash and [ __ ] which
is the black ash so just a little bit
about the nationwide collection program
because this program you know it extends
beyond our efforts here in New York
State as I said it's a u.s. Forest
Service effort so there's collections
happening you know all over you know
from Ohio down into the southeast in
Massachusetts it's a really big almost
nationwide effort that we're a part of
which is pretty exciting and the general
gist of it is that we want to collect
these seeds to preserve the genetic
diversity of ash and I'll explain a
little bit more about that in a second
but in essence we're losing these
species to an invasive insect emerald
ash borer which i'm sure the majority of
you have heard about now so these seeds
will be stored long term up to 50 years
in a u.s. Forest Service seed bank down
in Georgia and you know so that way
researchers and breeders will be able
to look at the genetics of these trees
and see if they can't you know breed a
more resistant species or you know look
a little more about why some trees are
more resistant than others and not only
that you know the potential for these
seeds to be used in future restoration
efforts once we have the problem of
emerald ash borer under control fingers
crossed that we do one day so to tell
you a little bit more about emerald ash
borer as I said I assume if your citizen
at New York State you have an
infestation somewhere near you here in
the Catskills where unfortunately home
to the largest one of the largest now
and fastest-growing infestations in the
state so animal ash borer is a little
teeny tiny beautiful insect which is
shipped to Asia it arrived here in the
States a long time ago probably in
Detroit first and it came in and packing
material for car parts so it you know
came to those those car factories that
Detroit famous for and started infesting
trees in Michigan and pathologists for
really scratching their heads over it
because trees start to show symptoms of
infestation before the bug is actually
visible so you know they'll start
dropping leaves their canopy will fin
they'll just you know look off and they
have this thing called epic Oryx proud
in which is when leaves actually come
out of you know the trunk itself or the
base of the tree and it's just a sign of
stress that there this issues that they
use for transporting nutrients and water
are being compromised so it's discovered
in Michigan in 2002 and it came to New
York in 2009 and now it's in over 24
states and at least two Canadian
provinces probably more than that it's
incredibly fast moving and hard to track
because it it will be transported in
infested material like logs and ashes a
very popular useful timber
um goofin black light species of ash
that position before their very special
and I'm currently expecting nearly a
hundred percent mortality in forests and
ash forests across the state and you can
see that it happens really fast if you
live near ones at the Centers of this
where i live in the catskills it arrived
first in woodstock around 2009 probably
a little earlier it came and already we
have over ninety-five percent mortality
in in those areas i mean asher dead and
have fallen and you know its name is
over so we're looking at functional
extirpation of this species this is a
huge blow to not only the ecology that
these trees are a part of but you know
also economically as i said it's a very
important timber species so to take a
little look at you know by this mattered
so much they said you can see on the
left that map is it's a distribution of
accra by county so it's kind of like the
density of ash in each county so you can
see up by commentary oh there is a ton
of ash i mean that's like thirty percent
ash in this forest there so this is a
huge huge blow to lose those trees but
it's a very common tree species
throughout the state there somewhere at
seven percent of our forest there ash
and there on the right is a map from
last year that looks at sort of some the
core areas of where the EAB infestations
have gotten started and how they're
spreading so the black is like you know
the trees are dead and dying and the red
is how it's sort of spreading out from
there and to see more updated maps if
you say update them you know maybe once
or twice a year you can look that on the
Department of Environmental Conservation
website so this is just a closer look at
some of the biggest and fastest moving
infestations interstate a lot of urban
and suburban infestations ashes of very
pop
dealer street tree because it's you know
super Hardy and tolerant to pollution
and compaction and things like that so
you know a lot of these streets have ash
trees that are going to be falling on
houses and cars and you know it's it's a
pretty serious problem across you know
many sort of spheres and one of the ways
that state has been trying to deal with
this problem is by setting up porn
cheating this particular strategy was
enacted last year I think it was maybe
last May or somewhere around there so
this little have drawn stations and
they're trying to limit or regulate the
infested materials that are moving in
and out of those areas because as I said
it's really very hard decisions gonna
pop up because they're more firewood
round all the time if you don't burn
piece of firewood or you know you're
transporting to murdering flight season
one of these little larvae can
metamorphose and just fly out of that
infested wood as you're driving along um
so that's we have these rules about
don't move firewood more than 50 miles
per flies in New York State because this
is how these forest pests gets get
transported so you know some of the
other way is to deal with it other than
quarantines are remove the trees and
replacing them with something that you
Nash be great and some natives a lot of
these food ash are natives but they come
from sort of Midwestern stock so we you
know we like to think about you
genetically local feedstock you know
makes things kind of more accustomed to
vagaries of our which is fine and stuff
like that you can use insecticides
insides do work ash trees um so long as
they're not super infested however this
beautiful specimen tree or a great seed
producer or something hanging over your
house you know by all means that's a
great option to treat it but again
you're gonna treat it for expensive
patrols natives like woodpecker
non-native some there are a few species
of wasps that are right now that are
pretty effective parasitoids you know
however they do target some of our
native ash borers and by the way are in
the dashboard not a not a problem
federal up scores are ash trees are
adapted and evolved to deal with our
native gosh / and then there's see
corruption as a great management option
i'll tell you a little more about that
why we like seed collection so much he's
you know outside factual habitat so if
we can't stop a bee we can take their
seeds and bank them and ensure that
those trees have a chance survival later
on in the future it's fast and it's
inexpensive which is huge like I said
you know cutting down trees and treating
with insecticide very expensive he
collection very you know comparably
cheap you can do it for a long time and
anyone can do it which is why we're
having this webinar because we would
love for you guys to help huh so as I
said this grant has been going on for
three years last year we've had a huge
sea so ash is amassing species like oaks
for example which means that they tend
to have sort of a mass massive seed
production year huh so this is to
overwhelm seen predators and stuff like
that you just put all of your seeds into
one year and that way you make sure that
at least some of them survived eat
burgers so we collected like crazy last
fall we had a ton of volunteer who were
involved in scouting for us it was about
75 80 people who were scouting for us
and then we have 60 folks we're actually
making collections this is all across
New York State and weezer New York State
as divided into eight these eight we're
neck ecoregions so that's how we make
sure that we're kind of getting a lot of
diversity of different trees growing in
different habitats the state to be more
you know evenly dispersed less
processing and we made 200 pictures was
way above 150 collections for the actual
grant that we obligated to do we had
tons and tons of white ash you know
that's a very easy species to find we
had a good amount of green a little
harder to find and I mean not too much
black I'll up later um mr. crow Kerry is
where people don't ya go very often
didn't get too many collections of those
second everything so we were thinking
you know wow is a see this gold watch
without 223 collections what can we do
this year since it's probably not going
to be another mass year these trees have
really exhausted themselves by this huge
bumper crop year in 2015 so what we did
is we thought about you know species
that are associated with ash so what are
the species that are going to fur as
well once trees that dominate the canopy
die and happen we preserve their
genetics their diversity so we came up
the list of species that were as I said
more associated with these ash force and
we did this primarily by looking at new
york's natural heritage programs data on
ash forests and then we took out any
rare species any species that has
orthodoxy which means that you can't
preserve it for more than a more
new year has a really high moisture or
oil content we can't list 22 species and
I was hoping that today could go through
some of these because they're you know
they're all relatively common but I knew
we don't only have an hour for this
webinar so what I'm going to say is if
you have an interest in plants and you
think you would like to do some
collections of these associated species
then get in touch with me and we can go
through some of the ones you know you
could pick five or ten to kind of get
really really good at identifying and
then could collect those seeds and
contribute to our seed bank all of these
plants are they produce seed seed in the
fall so I just started collecting some
of them now it's a little bit
challenging challenging because you have
to collect from a large population so
over 50 plants but it's really fun it's
a great way to improve your plant ID and
like I said it's it's part of this
really big growing network of seed
collectors working the conserved native
point so it's important work and we were
going to focus on these associated
species this year but then all of them
we started getting reports that lo and
behold some ash we're actually still
producing seeds so since that's sort of
the focus of our grant we continue
hammering on fraxinus and trying to get
more collections of Ashley particularly
the green and the black ash so we need
your help so what I am going to do then
is get through if I can advance the
slide is go through the identification
of these three different common species
of ash that we have in New York State
and what our seed collection protocol is
and in the hopes that some of you might
be able to help us out so this is a
white ash fraxinus econo and I would say
this is you know one of the easier this
is the easiest ash to identify not
only because it's very common and
abundant but because it just sort of
well maybe I've been looking at too much
ash but I think it just sort of jumps
out at you you often see it along
roadsides and old fields it's more of an
upland species you know it inhabits
drier soils and the other two species
that will talk about but characteristic
of the ash is it has what we know as
opposite leaves so the leaves actually
come off of the main stem opposite one
another and there aren't you know to too
many other tree species that are going
to do that you know the maples do that
boxelder does that that's actually a
maple but you want to make sure the
first thing that you're looking for is
those opposite opposite leaves and
opposite branches and that's a picture
of a white ash there and white ash has
you sort of broader leaflets so those
two things that you're looking out there
that's an entire leaf the little leaves
coming off our are known as leaflets i
wish i had a pointer so white ash has
these sort of more rounded chunkier
wider leaflets whereas green green ash
has more lancia lights in their leaflets
that's a good identifying feature also
white ash has pale undersides so you
could think y dash white undersides or
white ash wide leaflets and then green
ash is screen green all over Greenidge
also to this kind of glossy Sheen to it
I find a little glossy ER than the other
two and then here is a black ash leaf
which like I said it black ash is more
difficult to find because it likes you
know sort of wetlands or it grows a lot
in the Hudson around here and this sort
of the title swamp area so it's not like
a white ash or green ash where you're
driving along and yeah I got a dozen
there's mashed you kind of rare that you
would be able to see a black ash that
way so again in these pictures here the
whole thing that you're looking at
the leaf and those little leaves coming
off those relief lips so with black ash
the leaflets are sessile which means
that they just sort of sit right on that
central stem they don't have a little
teeny stem coming off that connects them
to that central stem at central stem
that's called a tragus I'm trying not to
do too much mechanical terminology so
those leaflets are just sitting right
there on the stem and I think another
another good way to determine black
ashes it also has this kind of flaky
bark in comparison to the other two
which have quite regular grooved some
people say diamond-shaped bark and then
there are other ways which I don't I
don't find as helpful to determine the
species can see the black ash twig on
the left has a sort of shattered bud
some people call that an ice cream cone
terminal bud as opposed to the green ash
that's smaller terminal bud and then you
can also look at what we call leave
scars so if you pull off a leaf from a
stem that little sort of you know looks
kind of like the shape of a smiling
mouse where you pull the leaf off that's
the Leafs car so you know a lot of
characteristics on these ash can be
variable and they can actually often
look like they're sort of somewhere in
between G species I don't talk a little
bit about that later but with white ash
often the the Leafs car looks like this
crescent moon so I know someone who
reminds yourself with that by saying
white ash white moon so remembering the
shape of that blue scarf ah the seeds
are another great way to distinguish
between species and you would be looking
at feeds a lot when you get really good
you can determine them you know as
you're driving by at 60 miles per hour
the green Asher and use like really
tight sort of chunky panicles so the
whole aggregation there is called a
pinnacle
and green ash is that picture on the
left see how it's just really you know
big chunky clump of seeds and if you
drew are narrower as well and more I
guess tapered and then the white ash and
then the white ash the picture on the
right are much booster much sparser
panicles and then looking at the feed
selves up close you can see the
differences between the green ash and
the white ash the green being much
narrower and sort of more elongate and
the white ash with that broader base and
then the black ash is totally different
it's sort of almost oval-shaped and the
black ash well I'll get into this later
actually getting ahead of myself here so
let's for just to quickly review the
identification at those species you
remember you want a straight away look
for the opposite branching and ash have
these what we know is compound leaves so
I said you know that whole structure was
a leaf and the little things coming off
but our leaflets so that's a compound
leaf so opposite branching compound
leaves and then you know make sure
you're looking at multiple
characteristics so you can look at the
Leafs car or the buzz could deceive and
i think that the habitat you know
location where you're going to find the
species is really helpful too so as I
said white ash is usually more of an OP
plant species it can be found in an area
that gets you know sort of with higher
water table and then you'll see white
ash will start to ya called ash yellow
this will start to get a little stressed
because it like some can drier soils
green ash is maybe in the middle yellow
in the soil can be moist it can be true
and then black ash really likes wet wet
areas like sweat be so it's kind of a
spectrum that you have there
okay so moving on to our collection
strategy and protocol sorry I'm having
trouble this clicker there you go okay
so this is just kind of a an overview of
what we're going to talk about so we've
identified species you're going to want
to locate monitor some good seed trees
you know these just anywhere in your
local park or your back yard front yard
along the street you just want to make
sure that it's not a planted tree a good
way to determine that is you know you
first of all you identify that it's one
of the native species it's not an Asian
ash and it's not planted in a row you
know sometimes you'll see an ash tree
planted out in the middle of sort of a
really remote maintained lawn in a park
or something like that might be
questionable there that's planted or not
sometimes you can talk to park staff to
confirm them but you know we don't want
to be collecting the seeds and
preserving the genetics of these trees
that have you know questionable origins
and we don't know where they come from
we want to be collecting seeds that we
know are native new yorkers you know
because we care about our new york
natives then i'm going to teach you how
to check for seed maturity because it's
important to collect seed at the right
time make sure they're not to insect
damaged to tell you how to show fill out
the data sheet how to pick seeds and how
to handle them when you're done it
mentioned before our sort of general
strategy for this brand the three year
program was to make 150 collections and
those collections are divided supposed
to be divided evenly between those three
common speech so 50 collections of green
50 of white and 50 of black and we
exceed those collections we got 223
however we got you know something like
150 white 60 green and then the
remainder were black and as I said that
sort of tastes upon ease of
of finding since the white is so easy to
observe and we're trying to get these
trees sort of spread more or less evenly
across these ecoregions that I mentioned
before so you can see the map on the
right is a sort of finer grade map of
some of the ecoregions across New York
State these regions are based on things
like you know climate and soil type and
you know how much it rains um things
like this um and again that's just to
make sure we're capturing the most
genetic diversity possible in these
collections so our protocol generally
you know we're looking for a naturally
occurring trees as I said and you want
to make sure your trees 100 to 300 feet
apart so a hundred foot minimum between
your trees you know if you find three
trees and sort of in a cluster and they
all look great just make sure they're
not super close because you know it's
possible you could be collecting from
two trees that are you know connected on
the ground or something like that we
want to make sure that they're
genetically as different as possible
you're going to make one collection per
tree so not multiple collections on one
tree if there's tons tons of seeds all
in one collection if they seem to be
maturing at different times just all at
one collection then you're going to take
a regular grocery bag you know just one
of those paper bags and it needs to be
filled with at least two to three inches
of feed so it seems like a lot of seed
but generally of ash is producing seed
you have no problem filling it that high
and the paper bags are kind of neat
actually because the first crease line
is is pretty much where we want you to
you know it's sort of a minimum fill
line if you will and then you're going
to need to fill up the sheets you're
going to get a twig sample and you're
going to take a couple photos so it sort
of sounds like a lot but I promise you
it's not
but first you have to know when these
are ready to collect so we're going to
go through a shoot through a few images
of that so Ashley the whole structure is
called a Samara Samra and then start
maturing very soon so some as early as
mid-september we found last year and
they can really hang on the tree for a
long time so you know into November we
were collecting in an early December
flashing and you want to do is you want
to look for a brown ski coat so the seed
is actually inside the samurai samurai
helps with dispersal with wind so these
feeds can fly away from their country
and good spot to root and germinate and
the seats that drop early we often get a
lot of questions about this are often
damaged so don't worry about picking
them up from the ground because those
are natural abortions we want to be
picking off of the tree starting around
mid-september the only exception to that
is that black ash feeds don't actually
mature on the tree often their drop-off
so you can collect those from the ground
that's that's perfectly fine just make
sure you do these little checks which
i'm going to show you now to make sure
it's viable feed actually kill off
exterior of the sarah as is shown in
these pictures and if you can look
closely on the picture on the right it's
actually revealing the seed inside that
whole fruit the samurai structure and
you can see it has a brown seed coat so
that is key that's what you're looking
for that pale brown seed coat if you
peel open and you see that it's green or
white or triple door it's not filling
the whole cavity then the seed is either
bad or I'm not yet mature too early so
you want a pale brown seed coat and you
want to make sure it's nice and plump
and full so here are some good pictures
demonstrating that you can see on the
left that embryo is immature pale green
and then on the right you can see
be a great looking feed coming out of
that samra nice and full and also firm
so it seems a little floppy again you're
probably too early a nice firm with a
brown pale brown coat um if you don't
have the fingernails to tear open the
samurai you can also use a razor blade
but they're pretty easy to get and these
are just some more cut tests that show
you what it looks like inside that
samurai so on the left there you can see
that this really maybe half of its
actual mature size so not ready and
they're on the right same thing here are
some very good-looking seeds nice and
fall with those brown seed coats and
then you also want to look for insect
damage because this is a major major
thing to look for weevils are a huge
problem they love ash seeds and you
don't want to collect a tree that's
highly interested with weevils because
you know that seed is not that is not
viable it's damaged so sometimes you can
see that weevil which onic on a cut test
you can also to see it on the exterior
the last inside
penetrated the fruit to lay an egg and
then if you open it up inside this is
pretty common you can you can see this
it's kind of you'll see there's a little
larva inside who's munching away on that
feed so if you find an ash tree that has
good fruit you know go around pick some
seeds off of each side of the tree and
do an inspection if it seems like most
of that these are infested and just
forget it you've got a got a bad treat
don't know they're collecting from that
you want to you want to treat where the
majority of the fruits are you know nice
and fallen not invested ok so we've
identified the tree and a good crop the
seeds are full and mature not damaged
the next thing is to look at the data
sheet so this ash seed collection data
sheet I can either email it to you or
you can find it online at wws be org
looks a little scary but I assure you
it's very simple basic stuff like date
of collection what your name is what
species you're collecting from where you
are what the topography is the most
important thing is to fill out that
little black box in the top right-hand
corner which asks for your collectors ID
number and your seed lot number this is
how we're going to link you and your
seed to the actual and this data to the
actual collection of seeds that you make
so your collectors ID number is your
last name so my last name is mark wand
and then the number collections that
you've made so if you've made one
collection it would be Marquand 001 when
I make my 100th collection it'll be
Marquand 10 so that's your ID number and
then the seed lot number C lot ID is
Mars be so that's you know just a way of
showing that you are linked to our
project and this information also has
people on the paper bag that contains
the seed just as I said to make sure
information on that data sheet is always
linked
to that feed and if you're part of a
group you know if you're you're you as
Master Gardeners get together and you
want to do something for your town you
can come up with a unique collectors ID
number that's fine and then it'll be
stored in the bank under your group name
and you know if it ever comes to the
point where you'd like to use some of
your seed for your restoration or
whatever you can query based upon that
name and there's a picture of the paper
bag that has Clara my co-workers last
name homes it's her first collection so
0 0 1 and then it's marz be that's part
of the project that's that she's working
with that's the feedlot so in terms of
picking the seeds very easy very
straightforward just make sure they're
mature pick them off of the panicle you
know you don't need to put any other
material in the bag because that could
alter the moisture content of the bag so
just strip the seeds right off so you
can also toss them into a tarp sometimes
it I've had this experience where it's
been really windy when you're collecting
and you need something a little sturdier
than a paper bag because it just flies
away you can put a tarp under the tree
or I have you know I have rear bucket or
something whatever works for you so this
is the minimum fill line that I was
talking about you can see that crease is
right right at three inches so that's at
what we need at least if you want to
fill the whole bag go for it then you're
also going to need its weak sample and
this is for identification purposes we
had a few specimens last year that it
was just kind of like I don't know is
this green or is this white ash so
taking that twig sample comes about six
to nine inches long pull all the leaves
off and chuck it in the bag with the
seeds that can help with identification
for position is an important part of the
collection and then once the tweak and
the seeds have been collected you want
to label your bags just ignore these
pictures I don't know
we want to make sure you have your last
name and the number is a collection and
then Mars be and fold them down and
staple them make sure the seat doesn't
explode everywhere and then you're going
to send them off to midterms you bank
which is in Staten Island and we'll give
you that information when your
collection is ready and we go over all
your data before we actually send them
to the feedback before service you Bank
in Georgia and you're also going to need
two photos one is a close photo of the
trunk of the tree again for
identification purposes showing your
seed lot identification number on the
bag and then the other one is going to
be the whole tree and this is the kind
of see the landscape that the tree is a
part of and those so it's easier to just
email those photos of me Oh like should
you good copies but you know you don't
have to go through that whole filagra if
you don't want you and once you've
picked them you know I'm just basic
sense don't leave them in your car if
it's a super hot day you don't want the
seeds to roast they want to be you know
draw dry ish but remain cool you know
sort of around thirty percent humidity
that helps anyone you could put them in
and sort of a cool cupboard or maybe in
your basement if it's dry after the
city's get shipped to the bank they're
kept in that nice sort of cool sort of
dry ish climate and they're chilled also
to make sure if you missed any weevils
that the weevils will come out and build
you know it stay in that collection of
see um I think I just went over that
yeah oh and then yeah they're frozen it
very very very cold temperature so this
is how they're kept for up to 50 years
is because we essentially stopped any
metabolism that's happening in that seed
comes to a halt just pretty pretty
interesting and all of the information
about your collections are recorded in
this
your National Information Network that's
called grin so you can actually you know
look up your seed and see it there and
all that information in the in that
database so ways that you can help is
again helping us find these these trees
this fall it says I said it's a pretty
spotty seed production year but we know
that they're out there we've gotten
reports particularly from the sub and
around the Great Lakes so we're you know
we're trying to collect more green ash
and more black ash in particular but you
know we'll take whatever so long as it's
a naturally occurring tree if you're
interested in collecting other species
the associated species please do reach
out to me I would be happy to as I said
go through and sort of make a smaller
list of species that you could focus on
if you felt like that was something you
wanted to do and my email is a shot Mars
be at gmail com so a sh m AR s be at
gmail com and then there's another
project that we're also involved in with
multiple partners we're still kind of
coming up with an informational sort of
outreach toolkit for it but we're
working with the new york botanical
garden and the US Arboretum among others
to try and work on this question of ash
phylogenetics you know there's not a
whole lot that's known about the
distinction between species and the
fraxinus genus and the ash genus and so
this project is hoping to sort of take a
finer grade closer look at where the
stink shins maybe and this is going to
be you know really important for
determining which species are more
susceptible to emerald ash borer and how
we can assure that we're you know
conserving that's really important how
genus of trees and for that project we
need
citizen scientists to help us make
collections of feed and herbarium
specimens so that we can have samples
for the herbarium but also the DNA that
we need to look at those phylogenetics
so there's a number of different
projects that we have on our plate we
need a lot of help but I think it's you
know really fun way to be involved in
native plant conservation in a really
important college
I asked you to participate or is one
okay yeah one is all you need can you
collect from a jury that's already
inspected by the emeril asked for yes
absolutely yeah I mean sometimes if you
have a really badly infested tree it'll
put out what's called a stress crop so
it's just kind of like I'm dying I
better make a last-ditch effort to get
my my jeans out there and its prior
really hard but those seeds will be kind
of shriveled and empty so if you see
that your tree is interested and it has
these just make sure you do that
viability check if they look great we'll
take them are there areas in the state
and you are most interested in having
disease from oh yeah that's a good
question I mean yes we didn't get that
much seed from the Adirondacks last year
but from what I hear from scouts there's
not really much going on there so that's
one area that we we missed a little bit
last year but this year we're trying to
focus on lakes region and we're hoping
that because it does have such a heavy
heavy density of ash and the canopy that
we'll be able to find something so you
know all sort of a long like Buffalo and
Rochester along those that lakeshore
would be great but anywhere class
anywhere all right well if you don't
have any other questions come here
either we thank you again for joining us
and if I quality / for sharing that
information with us and good luck in the
month of heaven yeah thank you very much
Lori and thanks everyone for tuning in
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu